[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti perché moltissime
finestre dei nostri centri storici siano
chiuse venezia padova treviso verona
roma le finestre nei nostri centri
storici sono chiuse per diversi motivi
il motivo principale è che il
proprietario non ha le risorse
economiche per affrontare una
ristrutturazione
oppure semplicemente non ne ha voglia
non è a tempo non ne ha le capacità
molto spesso poi questi immobili si sono
succeduti di generazione in generazione
per cui i successori non se ne sono
occupati vi pongo un altro quesito
vi siete mai chiesti veramente che cosa
vuole un turista internazionale quando
viene in italia
bene io ho passato gran parte della mia
vita professionale a cercare una
correlazione tra questi due elementi tra
le finestre chiuse dei centri storici e
i desideri dei turisti quando vengono in
italia
voi direte sono due elementi che
apparentemente non hanno nessuna
correlazione tra di loro ma che se
studiati intimamente portano a un legame
straordinario che potrebbe creare dei
benefici economici e sociali alla nostra
bella italia impensabili
tornando alla domanda che cosa cercano
veramente i turisti quando vengono qui
in italia
ho potuto verificare che la risposta è
molto semplice
loro cercano di vivere il sogno italiano
cercano l'esperienza italia in che cosa
consiste consiste proprio nell
affacciarsi da una di quelle finestre
chiuse
magari sorseggiando un prosecco e
guardando una piazza rinascimentale e
barocca
dopo aver trascorso una giornata per le
calli di venezia vogliono immergersi
nella storia pensando che proprio lì in
quella piazza abbiano vissuto attori
poeti musicisti vogliono sentire le
vibrazioni di un mercato nei nostri
centri storici pieno di prodotti tipici
di urla di persone vogliono pensare che
proprio lì vicino ci sia una trattoria
tipica o un ristorante stellato che
hanno solo potuto sognare
leggendolo in una guida straordinaria
tutto il mondo è disponibile a pagare
anche delle cifre consistenti per poter
alloggiare in quelle finestre chiuse ma
in realtà non lo possono fare perché
questi alloggi non sono disponibili e
magari sono costretti ad andare in hotel
fuori dai centri storici in hotel che
sono in grado di soddisfare le loro
esigenze in curiosiamo c con un pochino
di numeri in italia ci sono 34,4 milioni
di abitazioni circa 19,8 milioni di
queste abitazioni sono le nostre case le
case con cui viviamo con la nostra
famiglie alle nostre prime case se poi
togliamo una parte di case destinate a
utilizzi gratuiti o utilizzi diversi
ci rendiamo conto che ci sono 6 milioni
di case in italia che non sono
utilizzate
guardiamo cosa succede da un punto di
vista turistico
l'italia conta 400 milioni di presenze
turistiche all'anno 400 milioni solo
l'otto per cento di queste presenze
turistiche alloggia in appartamenti in
locazione turistica messi a disposizione
per l'oro contro il 25 per cento della
media europea ma cosa sta succedendo a
succedendo quello che vi ho detto prima
6 milioni di abitazioni non sono
disponibili per questi turisti 6 milioni
di abitazioni non sono disponibili per
questi per esperienza professionale o
ristrutturato circa una quindicina di
edifici sparsi per le maggiori città
turistiche italiane
sapete cosa ha comportato questo un
aumento di 50 mila presenze turistiche
nei nostri centri storici che significa
che sono 50 mila persone che sono andate
a mangiare nei nostri ristoranti che
sono andate a visitare i nostri mercati
che hanno consumato nei nostri centri
storici
abbiamo assunto decine e decine di
giovani che si sono occupati
dell'ospitalità delle pulizie delle
manutenzioni per non parlare degli studi
professionali che hanno fatto le
progettazioni e delle imprese che hanno
lavorato a questo progetto e se
moltiplica assimo tutto questo per
centinaia e migliaia di immobili in
queste condizioni in italia ad una
capite che avremmo trovato molto
probabilmente una soluzione
domani mattina
per dare una scossa la nostra economia è
al nostro livello occupazionale pensate
a quanto sia indicativo del benessere
socio economico
lo stato di conservazione del nostro
patrimonio
è come se il nostro patrimonio
immobiliare forse l'unità di misura del
nostro benessere
ma allora che cosa possiamo fare per
favorire questo processo di
riqualificazione urbanistica nei nostri
centri storici
io penso che la ristrutturazione e il
restauro non debba più essere vista come
un attività di stampo privatistico
ma un'attività che porta un beneficio
pubblico qualcosa della res pubblica e
per questo lo stato per esempio dovrebbe
prevedere dei fondi dedicati a queste
ristrutturazioni oppure le banche per
vedere dei mutui agevolati la
definizione di immobile è quanto di più
sbagliato io abbia sentito in vita mia
in realtà gli immobili
siamo in questo meraviglioso teatro sono
dei veri e propri organismi viventi e
sono stati testimoni per centinaia di
anni nelle nostre rivoluzioni dei nostri
cambiamenti sociali nel susseguirsi
delle generazioni hanno resistito a
terremoti innovazioni tecnologiche
tumulti sociali pensabili per motivi
professionali
ho avuto l'opportunità di visitare
centinaia di immobili vuoti
sapete qual è la caratteristica
peculiare di questi minuti
loro odore hanno tutti lo stesso
particolarissimo odore proprio a
testimoniare che hanno un'anima che
hanno un cuore che hanno una personalità
un immobile chiuso nel nostro centro
storico rappresenta una ferita al cuore
della nostra società e tutto quello che
rappresenta la costruzione di nuovi
volumi senza pensare a colmare i nostri
vuoti è un'attività che ci dovrebbe far
riflettere
l'italia è la nostra linfa vitale e il
patrimonio immobiliare ne è la vera
spina dorsale sapete qual è il mio sogno
è quello di camminare per un centro
storico e trovare tutte le finestre
spalancate
riapriamo le nostre finestre al mondo
grazie
[Applauso]